uh James hey James Gunn The Golden Child
what's up boss yeah so I just saw your
movie oh Guardians yeah volume three
yeah you know just a contractual thing I
had to make now I'm with DC full-time
now I'm with you full-time uh you know
yeah Superman yep yep and we're thrilled
about it it's just uh what you didn't
like the movie no James the problems
that I loved it oh oh specifically
remember a couple years ago telling you
to maybe like phone that one in right
maybe just hang out your last Marvel
movie pull up pull a taika uh love and
thunder sort of I mean game is still on
it right and I care about those
characters plus it'd be unethical for me
to make a bad movie just because it's
for Marvel yeah but you didn't have to
go that hard did you no you didn't have
to save their franchise I I wouldn't say
I saved it I cried three times in that
theater I wasn't even trying that hard I
did like two drafts of that script Max I
felt like so much sad animal stuff in
there you know and cut back on the jokes
I honestly I'm surprised people like it
Superman movie better have 10 times the
crying raccoon so you're finished oh no
no